hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to drunk minecraft I'm
here with Wade and Bob as usual hi Wade
hi guys and I mark as punishment for the
last episode for all of us
mostly Bob oh we've been we've been
sentenced to life on this island with no
escape because if we try to escape bob
try to escape I leave my hoe cuz we need
that yeah the very I'm a mob that was
just there was aa knows nothing to it
just down all right here's your home
back shall it now okay so we're trapped
on this island of death thank you for
the Apple Wade your uncle so we have
here oh we need PvP on because I think
PvP is oh I can't because right click
raises my hoe for battle hahahaha broken
so I'm stuck on this island I've been
drinking for three and a half hours I do
not feel good at this point but I'm
still drinking the same amorous hour in
this like 40 ounce chalice my ice is all
melted it is warm and watered down by
the fell drinking it
what are you guys drink oh hey I'm
drinking a very appropriate beer up up
I'm bad at this la fin du monde which I
think it means the end of the world yes
something good it's something it's the
end of us because I got this wait what
do you have the end of our horrifying
minecraft wait how does that help us
I have this all I can do right anyway so
we're trapped on this island a way off
without swimming so I rewrite I have an
axe should I chop down the tree now or
later does it will it grow at all I
don't think if we can hope and pray the
if we bust those leaves we get one
sapling all right
actually no if if we cut the tree and
let the saplings or the the leaves die
normally what isn't it higher chance of
them dropping a sapling literally no
idea all right
I'm cutting the tree is this tree to
grow naturally though I don't know if it
works like all right I got the wood I'm
gonna make a crafting table Oh God why
did it take like are you going smooth
with the crafting table for a boat Oh No
all right we got one rounded table at
all right or blocks of wood all right
it's the most effective thing I guess we
should save those and make tools I guess
um can we make an airship haha I don't
think so I don't think we're gonna get
any help from anything
Bob's down the water table no I'm okay I
thought I thought it was can this be
lava all around us making a little that
would be great haha got a little extra
horrific give us our situation of true
peril undying nasai Matt dig because I
have a shovel I'm gonna create a mine of
sorts huh Wow oh my god aah what
happened I'm making a break for it toe
dude Bob it's not worth it oh well the
hose gone oh no our hoe whatever will we
do shut up okay what's right so I would
stand right here
now I'm gonna dig down I'm gonna have
we're gonna have so much dirt okay I ran
out of dirt to dig um Wade you got the
pic right yeah I hope it lasts the one
your turn to shine all right I'm gonna
try to we're gonna try to dig I'm
actually wait this is Bob
we lost Bob wait wait wait wait uh I'm
I'm fine uh I'm lagging I keep thinking
I'm falling in the lava all right I've
got 12 cobblestone what are we gonna do
with it don't know we're gonna try to
build out
so that we can escape to somewhere else
all right I'm right here take over man
we gotta survive this why do we make
this lava yeah I wanted to what nothing
happened Wade yeah you're good I felt
well acting like stuff happened and then
oh no oh wait
what the hell Wade you have the only pig
ah the oceans rushing at what no what
now ha ha ha
now we got that code but I can't break
blocks or anything so you can break dirt
get some dirt we need no I like because
of the game can't break blocks oh ok a
tidal wave just destroyed our bridge Oh
Bob is broken apparently that's what you
get Bob for what you did in the last
episode how dare you
I have no permission ha ha ha oh you've
been opt alright I can do stuff now hey
it's a miracle I want to get over to
those sugarcane over there that is
tantalizingly over there we're gonna
steal you how how is my draw distance
really short or something I don't know
things are going all wonky on this side
is this how lost is is is what lost is
like this how much was is our plane is
good um I have four planks of wood why
can you make sticks and we can make some
more picks out of stone yes actually
surprising listing stone right now
slowly our interesting stone with his
fist you can break stuff with your fist
so I guess you can no can I not take
these blocks if I break them with my
fist here Bob I got some underneath you
if we are really sophisticated Wade
could go down try to get iron and we
could get iearnt we need torches those
way yeah well I'm we have uh we need to
smelt it before we can make it into
ingots to make stuff with it no can't
make access per pixel over there wait no
I Oh poopy Martin mud don't move okay
this
don't is surprisingly valuable debate is
leader or did dial their own got it I
got it you want a pickaxe yeah that'd
probably be the best option I think all
right one that is not if I want another
hoe oh yeah don't tell me I will make
another oh okay I tossed you the
possessions epic waste of wood wait do
you want anything we got very few sticks
to waste here I know I'm good for now
I'm good at Ricky's if we find iron or
something oh yeah we really can't go
much lower huh I'm gonna make myself a
pickaxe and then that'll be it will
because we need to have like a shaft for
light to the surface or something yeah
oh ingenious but that's gonna take a lot
of effort and the water will come in
that's not going to work we need is a
center shaft but but we can have a dirt
on the outsides if this can work no this
can work like right above where the UM
were the the thing is like that center
shaft there we can do that you got a
barrel down wait why'd you break the
stairs I've did this are you whining are
you why widen it why didn't okay I get
it yeah so we get a little bit more
light in here like this why didn't water
it out quite it there huh that's not the
right place to widen it
I'm just try to get more light down here
so we can see you know why is what you
guys can't do anything right we're gonna
die here you know we could like draw
straws and eat you more hey you're the
wife I do we have draw straws for that I
was just try to make him feel better
about it
mmm oh that's water ah what did you do
no oh I like I fixed it okay oh my god
now I'm stuck in a thing Oh building it
up on the outside we're gonna we're
gonna try to do this correctly why are
we going down anyway are we building a
tunnel to the other Island that was kind
of my thinking I was gonna not tell
zombie that though oh well yes you know
no its if I just want that loudly yells
out our plans to Bob oh I don't know I
don't even know what you would say it
would just be obnoxious oh that's one or
two [ __ ] okay fixed it
I make the worst pads yeah I made it to
the sugar cane so what does that do for
us what can we do look at me looks we
could have gone to the like the hilly
island the other way oh yeah
why did we do here cuz you want to go
this way what did the sugar I thought
you had a plan hahaha I'm brown leaves
and hoping we get wood cuz they're not
dying where'd you get the leaves on top
like that blue we got sad legs to some
boy what the hell will you build that up
a couple so I don't have any dirt left
I've got some but I can't get out cuz
I'm trapped in the door doesn't build it
out Wade build it out out build it out
got one block I can't spell stupid while
I'm trapped here I like how we're like
we're all our blocks and I look back at
there's this giant ass bridge tool
little island of nothing alright I'm
gonna play the tree right there no
careful this sapling so there's light in
it oh I got a grow a tree ha ha ha well
it's somewhere else uh Wade there's
there's dirt all the way out on that
island what did you do I'm at ha ha ha
ha ha I made a slight error Oh your
error sound wow that means air or Wow oh
I'm recollecting this dirt over here
lovely from the absolutely useless
expedition to nowhere is that what your
recur collecting the dirt from his house
they complain my tree over there we're
kicking my tree I'll build a little
outcropping by the lyre and we won't
destroy it your but we're gonna have the
trees over the lava that's brilliant
yeah build it over here it'll be fine it
is probably good for trees right yeah no
me I put it out there don't be a baby
put it out there
grow grow who's got some bone mill word
yes I
bone meal tonight it is not actually oh
good it's almost night that's we're
gonna get monsters aren't we I don't
know we gotta cool the house but we
don't have torches or so [ __ ]
oh we're so [ __ ]
ah why are you breaking my [ __ ] the same
aside as you you broke my stairs I did
not break anything in that direction
why are there no stairs that question oh
oh I'm not doing well why are slow what
is with you squid what are you doing in
stack what are you doing look at this
stupid-ass squid its sack it just died
for no reason it died it was here just
Squidling and it just stupid like a
dumbass just died
what the hell we have any food or
anything why you get a little hungry in
this Apple that's apples it sure looks
good don't it mmm and I murder you
mmm oh my god I can oh I will I will
jump in the lava with the last of our
sticks oh don't you dare oh oh what why
why does this pit why this here now
lighter stairs from the outside goddamn
I have an ink sack don't mess with me
the hole get me out I feel oh we're
right here okay walk in front of me Wade
stop breaking the damn stairs that was a
stair nose a skier there it's right
there there are no stairs out there's a
way out there's a way out you know
there's gonna be a breeding ground for
monsters you know that right yeah well
let's not let that happen well we do
have some natural light coming we got a
lava get out of a ticket
holy [ __ ] what guys I have an idea
what except the lavas all gone now let's
go say we should build a house where
there's one square of lava that's inside
the house so there's light
but now the lavas all gone oh yeah our
trees aren't grown yet though or so
pound look at this other dumbass squid
over here look at this
ha ha kind of an idiot are you it's just
women in one block shallow water you're
so stupid
I think all of the water is one block
shallow dumbass squid here it's not a
[ __ ] idiot
alright so can we make it can Bob what's
so bad hmm this is the worst episode
ever should happen I don't think we're
smart enough to do this we're doing fine
just keep going we need to start digging
a tunnel then we've wasted all of our
materials build you pat the neg a tunnel
somewhere towards I'm building a
two-block tunnel hopefully I'll hit some
lava that I can use to light it err so
that's the wrong direction oh really
this torch which way this way that way
where you're facing this is this way
this direction here okay over here I'm
gonna see what under the stairs so I
don't break them okay I will help you I
will dig the other part of the two-ton
flooding no did this my dream
wait was it the domination wha'd why did
you do this I didn't come up here I
couldn't do this
why don't you the water to your other it
happened here let the battler dam why
must a tree like Porky Pig
build a dam we look at five blocks I got
it I got it I got it the hell's going on
I got it save the trees save the trees
save the trees okay we got it we got it
oh my god get more blocks we gotta build
along I guess the telly made water of
rye
Xabi why is it bright down here that
lava does not look good Bob it's safe
that's what I'm doing I'm using the lava
to light the solid red for this area it
actually is working surprise wave what's
wrong with you guys it's it's actually
working wait it's working just stop
panicking all right just use your pick
to get materials so that we don't flood
working on it oh no that's not this is
the wrong way we need to go I don't know
we need to get around this lava but all
I see iron Oh get it hard
get it get it get it get it get it yeah
I got it up don't go into panic there
may be a crabber down there or something
out I'm getting it there's a bunch of
iron
okay I'm gonna build a staircase so you
can get out I have a bunch of stuff I
can just ah flooding look at waves up
head your job is to stop the flooding I
was getting snag on it Wade go help Bob
I got it jeezum hey nor you are the weak
link here our tree Oh if our tree gets
washed away don't wait on me I'm I'm
down here and get material so I did you
didn't do it fast enough
obviously well clearly thank you for
Captain Obvious
alright I'm protecting our tree now oh
no I need more materials like for now I
need many more aha Oh God uh I'm
reclaiming oh no they're under water now
gosh it's bad news up here Oh gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
we need to protect a tree why haven't
these damn things grown yet oh because
they're not right get away you're stupid
okay alright this is so bad just keep
calm my pickaxe is about to go we got
we're gonna have more wood I've got
three sticks left so we got enough for
one more pickaxe
I'm just close to being out of pickaxe
and I appear to be the only one who
understands how to use a pickaxe I don't
think that's true either
all of mine has gone to Mars shenanigans
I got plenty on my pickaxe just get that
iron Bob up here or iron get deep get
the iron up here Bob my pickaxe Hey
the tunnel is slowly growing but what oh
right listen why do i trapped
abital no I'm kind of hey guys something
I did not do that
like on why is this tree glowing I did
not do that what am i trapped what's
going on you're not trapped
where are exit over here where are you
guys wait what the hell do you do when
you come down here everything goes to
[ __ ] the hell is happening I dug just go
up Bob you're not it anything that would
be a support you go tree will tree we
have a tree we have a tree honey down
with what your fist
oh uh I'm getting the rest of this iron
huh we're gonna have iron picks baby
we're gonna have iron picks I can't
believe it you have a chance
I mean Oh two furnaces I guess we don't
have enough fuel is there water unless
sometime orrible happens like right now
to stop this from succeeding for us
we'll be just fine I need somebody come
and dam this I'm coming I need to get
screaming damn it a little do we have a
furnace I've got two furnaces and I'm a
lotta lotta Lotta oh I used my iron to
block it up instead of my stone [ __ ]
mark he suck it was real oh my god why's
the water happening on now I gotta rally
I got a sapling oh yay thanks okay
thanks why is water here why is there
water here on and I'm workin on it
I should be damned off well it's the
tide rising so much this isn't cool I
got the rest I think you need to just
constantly be building this dam up I've
gotta have materials with that I'll make
some materials we have plenty of
material somehow yeah it just doesn't
have any there's a giveaway that's a
hole in the ground where you can do what
ever you want here here
somebody there's wood and trees and
sticks this water go away it's like
permanently here what are we gonna did
we find any coal just put a block in it
and then destroy the block I'm out of
material I got it I got it I got a guy
there we go
should go away I need stuff to build a
wall and I don't have a pickaxe and yes
look going away
SOT going away it's like a spawn block
hang on okay there we go is that okay
okay I got it got it got it
Oh what Bob I fell and insta died
because you were starving
yes okay I'm back okay wait here have
some cobble I you maybe throw it into
the ocean jeez
wait stop moving Brad oh my god right
here cut okay just take that make sure
the dam here give this dumbass squids
what the hell good thing I got this
sward here there's there's I make it
worse you Madison
I made a sward back when bob was
eyeballing my goodies I had to protect
myself I didn't know what was gonna
happen give you guys everything wait how
are you gonna get up there after you're
done I'll build my way back up when I
get more material all right fine are we
gonna use wood to UM cook this you have
to don't we all right we're putting wood
in can I please have a work bauble I
don't have any more cars I'm onco
harvest we're cooking up your night
America
I got some just let me what stand still
stand still
how have we not killed each other yet
that's because everything else is
dangerous enough I already died a bunch
well the face of adversity we're
actually not doing too bad well bad that
drink is oh my god it's lava winners ha
ha ha ha water save us
ha me master
housing over here I don't know what the
hell like the second we say we're doing
okay it says no get the iron out of
there I need to build iron picks I think
we just got it once we get these iron
picks we just got to go for it
like in the tunnel and then just I block
this off and you guys destroy the blocks
uh we got it get the iron out of there
there should have been six pieces
oh my god I'm drowning help help oh oh
oh oh oh okay I don't let me build a
roof over the iron alright cuz if we
close this in it it'll just I don't have
the iron it's in there oh it's in there
okay this is easier and cheaper though
to build like one small structure of
light that it is to keep the entire
thing open all right I got to iron
pickaxes Bob you take all the sticks
just fell Oh
guys we're about to flood again about a
blog Bob take that we're going down we
need to put a roof on this way that's I
think you're right we need a roof
desperately I'm gonna get a Baba I don't
know where but I'm gonna get a bunch of
cobble from somewhere we're now
completely flooded oh my god do anything
about it like the only thing I have is
wood fun here Oh Bob are you drowning no
I'm actually fine I'm in a little okay
just gonna get whatever you can and
bring it up we're gonna put a roof on
this sumbitch we just need to get a roof
on it and we'll be fine
how are we gonna get rid of the wall
will you put blocks there these are the
only blocks that are the ones that exist
up on top hope it looks like infinite
water yeah we probably should have put a
roof much much sooner yeah probably
okay I thought my iron pick just broke
that was totally my stone pick we could
have burned some of the wood to make
coal wood make torches to light this up
gonna try and come back up
okay oh my god this is really far I'm
gonna drown you'll be fine you can make
it you can make it you could piss you
can make it I'm coming you can make any
Bob Bob good I'm good I'm good good good
I'm good it's hydra-matic Eric come back
whatever the word is that I'm looking at
I dry Mackel Mac ashesh yeah that's it
to build this just fill it in it doesn't
matter just fill it in except for one
spot so that we'd go in and then that
will be fine well let's leave let's
leave
oh god this is the stairs over here
right here yeah where I am let's leave
this and we'll leave this as the stairs
alright on the good the good news is it
is destroying the water so wits we're
getting aired out here again good so
fill it in there Bobbo imma going
goody-goody it's gonna get real dark
here though there's a bunch of lava
openings I've been working on can you
make a bunch of lava light in there we
should it's really dark can you make
charcoal
I cannot cuz I don't have any actual
wood blocks I have saplings though all
right I think I just covered all the
water and we have a roof yep yeah we
actually did something more facing
adversity and succeeding yeah
now what just to the mines uh I don't
know I don't know man let's break these
tables and stuff and take them down with
us and just close this off and go and
use the lava for light and forget the
water uh maybe
you mean like the matrix [ __ ] the
outside world yeah yeah yeah exact what
wha what I'm closing us in what happened
bull yeah just what is closed
Oh take the crafting table it's coming
down ready goodie I'm right below it
give it to me it's terrifying well
that's their time look we don't all
right we got about five minutes left II
uh furnace this - if we go straight down
yes way
we've survived we've done what is that
sound
no what oh no [ __ ]
there's water it is redstone torches
over here okay having those hey what why
would there be redstone torches job as
if someone's trying to stop us God oh
I'm battling the water with cobblestone
it's not going very well
oh let's just try to dig out we got to
dig to freedom like just take what we
have and try to make a tunnel out of
here
are you guys I'm down on the bottom of
the mine I'm trying to find a way around
the lava I'm gonna keep walling walling
off behind us so we're like
compartmentalized away all the
explosions and [ __ ] I don't think that's
gonna help us though I'll drop this
noble we are probably oh no he's setting
more he's setting more lava lava lava
lava lava all right I'm gonna try a new
strategy no one come near me because
this might go horribly horribly wrong ah
help no helping you where are you Bob Oh
what was that
did you just hit me I'm sort of mine I
do hit me hi Bob this little thing I'm
gonna build this tunnel I've got two
torches and I'm gonna keep working my
way out uh just one by two Joey
Oh guys I've made a boo-boo boo-boo stop
making me a news nope no panicking we're
perfectly fine all right his follow-up I
just did a huge vein of iron oh if only
that was useful to us in any way so far
why is this flooding wait what are you
doing here and you got to keep us close
Tin Man I'm right with you no blocks in
here get in here
here take this mark do you have any wood
left I have yes possible the way we can
turn these six in amazing yes actually
we could here take them surprisingly no
not Lane wait what are you doing there
it's right there what oh there we are
okay do you have the furnaces plop down
the furnaces oh oh do you have the
crafting table though yes I do have a
load of cobblestone okay crafting table
down
okay look what doing this this is some
this is actually pretty impressive I
think haha very like Zeus himself is
after us
wait I saw smoke zombies in here with us
zombies in here with us is in here with
us
okay I'm putting half the wood we have
in one of those furnaces oh god I fired
the rest I'm sure nothing Oh
Oh No gather bub I don't I don't die
don't die the spawn is outside me was
waitin I forgot the spawn was far away
ah I can't stand it
wait oh well one is inside the roof
isn't it what uh I'm trapped I'm trapped
down here now
wait what's happening we're inside
something I don't know where we are do I
have all my stuff oh hey how's it going
hey guys how you doing mark where are
you I'm in the tunnel where we were
Byron's cooking here oh my god I have
all my stuff
everything's hunky-dory actually
surprisingly like I'm gonna Matt I'm
gonna make some more iron pics
wait this is where the lava was I
remember now you're on picks who wants
some iron picks hey hey what I'll have
one but I'll take extra haha we're
actually surviving yay I mean we don't
have any food or any way to get food so
you know wait wait I've got some here we
just got to make a totally it was done I
just mean that's a pretty big survival
thing that we're not really doing
yeah we just got to make we just got to
get a tunnel out of here
so can I open this lava up a little bit
to give us some light yeah if you know
how to do it don't kill her don't stand
right next to me okay are there there
was it it was I turn light on it end we
got out got some legs okay oh oh all
right lava everywhere I see you zombie I
see your smoke trails I know you're in
here with us
I'm getting paranoid guys I'm getting
very high uh-huh this lava um I saw
smoke on Wade wager the enemy yeah I've
been hearing all along okay all right
um we have a lot of light yeah but
you're trying turn right but you don't
stand there wait this might go horribly
wrong I'll help you I'll dig on the
right side okay boo this is actually
pointed in the wrong direction by the by
this is a way this is towards that
little boy there's literally lava
everywhere oh my God we're gonna die
we're gonna die we're gonna die probably
and actually we are out of time
surprisingly Oh No well you wait what
did you do I did not do that Wayne oh my
god anything to do with this lava is now
dripping from the ceiling oh oh oh that
was not there before okay we're actually
officially out of time so I think for
this survival expedition we all died in
a valiant effort to get off the island
like this no no no don't don't don't
don't kill us we all died of starvation
in or cannibalism but uh and or so
zombies send us off an explosive fashion
I got apples well we did so well I know
that's light that we made I know we were
surviving we were doing pretty good
agora sri good job Wade you grew that
one tree no part - uh should we continue
our expedition we could do a part two
mom the story never ends actually it's
like lost this is all we ever do now
yeah so anyway this is we we have
struggled to survive ins and actually
done pretty impressively well for what
we've done for what we started well
Adaline's I see I'd say that's the truth
if zombie wasn't out to get us the
entire time we would have been off that
Island not to him I don't know why I
took us so long to figure out the roof
thing that was that was pretty stupid so
zombie who's the intermediate winner of
this one I came up with the roof I'm
just saying who did the best to hell I
survived and
all the other important [ __ ] Bob you
lose twice for screwing everything else
up yeah oh yeah that's right guys I'm a
leader I'm a leader I don't know what I
did but I'm a leader I I guess I told
you to dig the mine yeah that's what I
did that's wait you just took my no wait
give me that torch my torch I don't have
a torch all right so what we're gonna do
is thank you everybody for watching
we're gonna keep this here we're not
gonna blow it up we're gonna keep this
where we last left off we were trapped
in the tunnels together huddled for
warmth naked surviving off of mere body
fat and stones well Wade ate gravel but
he's pretty stupid anyway so yeah we're
gonna just sit here this is we thought
with it we didn't think this idea would
go this far so thank you all so much for
watching sake bye guys goodbye guys I'm
not gonna be like that I'm gonna say
goodbye yeah
if y'all don't follow Bob on Twitter a
subscriber late on a channel there is a
Twitter channel so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation more
videos that we've done yeah as always we
will see you in the next video
Oh
bud